[Music]
and uplifting news
oh honey positivity in my life submitted
by a bar topless citizen tell me tell me
about this we have three citizens now in
the city of bar top a list that's like
Joe Mallya but Bart's he has a city
state it's a it's a new country and you
can't you gotta be willing to be pretty
cool this is all about Steve City
Steve's description sounds like it's for
your city now everyone should have a
city state oh I think yours more like a
country and then these are cities I'm
I'm a nation why don't why do you gotta
swallow all of us up we can't have our
own independent city-state is separate
city state is like so back in the Greek
days everyone was a city-state but you
have your own cut there is no one
country so your country have an empire
it's a net it's a country Empire people
damnit get on the [ __ ] it up I'm a king
that turn Emperor Steve City borders the
the nation of TIF my city borders
insanity so that's what that's where
it's at right David's wasteland David's
the no-man's land
you don't even go to that's right that's
where all the shitty [ __ ] you get rid of
you love mm-hmm Honda elephants forever
I know it's like the official car
despite scary media coverage here are 40
ways the world is actually getting
better
oh nice what's here I want to know do
you know what the world is actually
getting [ __ ] better like Oh mr. CLE
objectively it's getting better compared
to history but that doesn't sell and the
news don't [ __ ] like positivity
dreams true so true because
you know we try to do positive articles
on Jake aim is to try to uplift the
world and [ __ ] but no one clicks it so
we don't do those anymore they're right
case and [ __ ] point
people love drama watch this video get
know like sometimes I just want to like
put on my titles like for my tiles
they're very straightforward and it's
actually what happens in the videos and
it doesn't do very well for it but if I
write I get faced spot we dramatize it
it's so bit wild but then you know what
I'm thinking it but then I'm pissed if
you don't get facebook yeah exactly
where's the face [ __ ] man come on
yeah so there's this website called
human progress org and they narrow down
like 40 ways in how the world is getting
better I followed them yeah I followed
them on Twitter I forgot to put it on
airplane mode but I want to prove it to
you right now it's pretty dope I don't
think I think that's impossible it's
such a small thing to me no way that's
pappad confirm it I confirm he does
follow them it's done telling you guys
about
thank you follow someone on Twitter I
follow human progress it's very good but
you don't follow their Instagram no
Facebook only Twitter and their website
no only stock yeah I know I'm not a real
fan I follow car magazine on Twitter I
can prove it to prove it nothing to do
with positivity yeah well I mean the
typing you follow them is positive the
dopest yeah I've ever heard of my life
you what does that feel like when you
make the room silent what does that feel
like it's like we're all on a train and
then it gets completely derailed and
we're all like I know this is horrible
and Anjos like I found a quarter on the
track
positivity I hate that person
shut the [ __ ] up that's what she reeled
the Train [ __ ] don't be happy about
all right so one of the ways is in fact
that more people than ever owned a
personal computer okay use it for porn
that was inspirational
all right and just over a decade and has
become substantially easier to start a
business
oh yeah yeah good posit and everyone
fails how about that how about a porn
business failure rate has never been
higher - more people than ever have
access to sound money Oh sound like
money you can trust or like sound money
55 cents see is that what it means
yeah I think it's stable currency no
more corrupt government we understand
there was a point in Germany with our
like burning their bills right because
the money wasn't stable yeah and that's
what put the Nazis in power so now
they're saying that the money is sound
and you could actually trust it that's
good for children age 7 and under the
expected average years of schooling has
never been higher we can crop it all
they feel like if they tell us it's all
that that fools like [ __ ] that's why it
clap yeah but more homework [ __ ] dad
that's not positive that's true more
education is positive but more doesn't
mean more time wow this is clap this is
a good thing cause technical man have a
great education what the purpose of the
son is what is the purpose of the son
jail so they could give us vitamin D da
[ __ ] that's where the God lives
welcome to public school I thought the
purpose of this as we could
draw that in the corner of your drawings
and put sunglasses on it he's not lying
he drew that oh yeah changes I want to
break all the rules and I put them dead
center how did we go to different
elementary schools but everyone did the
same [ __ ] because we all equally didn't
learn anything in all our we all
progressed like we all learned there's
like the levels of what we learn let me
be specific the Sun colored like the Sun
thing we're learning shapes we were all
in different schools but everyone did
the Sun with sunglasses and [ __ ]
Mickey Mouse Club those cartoons all had
that [ __ ] yeah and we were just ripping
off cartoon that's the real school hey
do you guys know something called the
Renaissance Fair did you guys have that
I've been there in elementary school
yeah always wanted to go I wanted to go
to it's pretty fun this is why people
cosplay right you basically have any
titties like you have four sets and
they're just but they're like choices
it's an unfortunate titties fortunate
because they're scooped up and pushed up
and but be nobody wants to see him yeah
but see the like cuz they're all fat
girls no that's another way of putting
it oh hey hey lately lately I've been
liking chubby girls oh you're that face
this year yeah you said you have phases
and girls are it what is it what does
chubby though - you know there's so
there are so four girls five six what's
chubby - you know it's it's the poundage
yeah like they're obviously big but
their shape is nice you know I mean like
thick fit yeah like they do have a
stomach and [ __ ] but they don't look
disgusting you like to think like fit I
don't know what that mean
I got it draw it for you but I can't I
can't gauge if like number talking about
though it's like girls they're big right
clear when you see they're bigger chicks
but they still got a nice figure to them
right so there's still proportion like
Nicki Minaj
like that oh I like that Nicki but no
it's not that no no no it's fatter than
that Nicki Minaj not fact that model
Ashley there's Ashley Graham Ashley
Graham is thick and beautiful can you
show me yep I need to see grandpa
Nicki Minaj's ladies are bigger than
mine so I feel like she's pretty thick
I'm pretty sure they're not really yeah
booty but she's not yeah yeah yeah it's
not a she's not a big girl though cuz
Thicke is still yeah I mean I'd say look
so if she had like a bigger belly and
her arms were like marshmallow and her
face was a little more round I'd still
be cool with that if her proportions are
right how kinds as our proportions are
correct mm-hmm
I like some like if you go to Target
they're like the plus-size models yeah
I've never been in that section they're
all attractive acres not she to fat in
between in between her and the other
girl okay but you know what though I
have to say she does have a pretty face
yeah so she has to say MIOSHA is here
you don't have to say I think you have a
pretty face on it's okay but my range of
what I thought was beautiful has opened
up I like how we have taken an article
about positivity and to degrading fat
women creating them yeah exactly raiding
women and integrating fat woman you all
I gotta say is a couple years ago my
spectrum wouldn't even go this far like
this is this is just like all the other
ones this wait for maybe you're like
hang on I actually like big women to hit
me in like okay but like it's gotta be
like a certain type and like oh no no
she's too way too fast
I don't even like chubby girls now of
this video dad can I pay for this video
not there
nobody's funny because it was liked it
was like there's more children that have
computers now I know I like you guys
girls I understand chubby girls can be
beautiful too that's all I'm saying
you know who I am I've dated a bunch of
fat women lucky you know how cool I am I
am a fat woman what about the computers
and the hands yes I mean it was your top
five
stop fat shaming guys you're prejudiced
against me because I said that I think
fat girls are cute we're trying to save
this guy by going to the next subject
what does they hold on let me just bring
this right back hey tell me some other
positive [ __ ] access to improved
sanitation facilities have skyrocketed
that's amazing
he's still letting it at the public
beaches though like let's not forget
those that one camp site we were at had
amazing public facilities yeah no
surprise in a very nice Doogie and I
brushed my teeth in great comfort really
yeah did you take the Dookie first or
after the teeth brushing I'm trying to
take a Dookie first was it a nice
facility it was super clean it smelled
like fresh air yeah cuz normally like
rest stops then you gotta like basically
step on the toilet to [ __ ] in it you
know what I always find in the [ __ ]
right stop there's always a brand new
roll of toilet paper that is soaked in
piss yeah it's probably kids man they
[ __ ] piss on it everywhere you know
what's even crazier at those rest stops
you know those rest off right there in
the middle of nowhere right yeah but
somehow these like little shanty towns
have gangs where they want people to
know who they are like listen dude
nobody comes here you know that's like
representing route 76
unity they want us to know how to carve
up the mirrors I'm like what the [ __ ]
and traveling gates yeah
games on a road trip yeah like there are
dawn a family road trip and [ __ ] the
claiming small territory but they still
have the gangbang yeah on their family
vacation [ __ ] funny bet coyote creek
Bloods it's like this Warner potty is
belongs to this gang dog and then and
they do it on the toilet seat I mean
they were on their knees in that dirty
ass bathroom carving that [ __ ] out
that's disgusting they don't think
before the tag yes thank you for you tag
kids think before you tag
[Music]
you
you